there has been a lot of talk about the
patient protection and affordable care
act often referred to as obamacare
usually by those who are not a big fan
of it and my goal here is to not take
any political sides and hopefully give
an overview of what all of the debate is
about and what this affordable care act
is all about and i'm going to start with
the most controversial part and this is
the individual mandate and this is the
idea that you either have to get
insurance or
pay a penalty or a fee or tax
penalty which is now being referred to
as a tax by many folks and the indict
and the idea here insurance the idea
here is that there are obviously many
folks who are uninsured right now and
when they get sick especially when they
get very sick they still get health care
then in particular they will go to the
emergency room
they will go to the emergency room and
that is quite possibly the most
expensive part of the health care system
to interface with so there's kind of a
moral argument here is that one these
people are getting sicker than they need
to get if they had insurance then they
would get preventative care and not get
that sick and then there's a financial
or i guess you could say a fairness
argument that these people are getting
sick going to the emergency room they
have to be given care at that emergency
room
the hospitals bear those costs and then
eventually the hospitals recruit those
costs by charging more for all sorts of
other services which eventually go back
to the people who do who are paying for
insurance who actually are paying for
the health care and so if you have an
individual mandate it'll clear things up
a little bit people will have to
essentially pay for the health care that
they are already
getting now the argument against the
individual mandate is that this is the
government
putting into law saying that people have
to buy something in particular that they
have to buy health insurance now the
counter argument to that that many
people make is well there's something
similar going on with car insurance if
you want to drive in most states you
have to buy some type of car insurance
or at least show that you have the
financial ability to pay any liabilities
that you might have if you get it into
an accident now the counter counter
counter argument to that is well car
insurance is is is not a is is something
that someone or driving is something
that someone chooses to do that you
don't have to drive while in the case of
health insurance this is something that
this is every human being in the on in
the in the in the country is being
forced to get i'll leave it to you to
decide where you sit on that and what
what balances what other issue
now obviously if you're going to decide
whether you want insurance or whether
you're going to pay a penalty or a tax
you have to figure out how high is that
penalty or tax going to be on you or if
you want to figure out if this is a fair
situation you have to think about how
high is that penalty or tax going to be
and the current provision say that by
2016 and this is when the full penalties
take effect you're going to have to pay
the maximum of either 2.5 percent of
income
of income or
695 dollars for an individual
and 2085 dollars for a family and there
are exceptions this will not this whole
individual mandate won't apply to you if
have getting insurance would cost you
more than eight percent of your total
income
or if you
belong to a religion that does not
participate in the health care system
then it doesn't apply and also you will
never have to pay more than eight
percent of what it would cost for you to
get a health insurance policy but these
are the general policy the general
penalties and just to get an
understanding of it if you made a
hundred thousand dollars and chose not
to get the insurance you'll the 2.5
percent is 2500 which is more than
either of these numbers and so you will
pay twenty five hundred dollars if you
if your household makes fifty thousand
dollars then the two point five percent
would be less than this year and so you
would pay you would pay this number
right over there now the other
provisions of the affordable care act
really are all around well if we want
people to get insurance we need to make
it easier for them to get insurance and
the biggest deal at least in my mind is
this one covering pre-existing ex
pre-existing conditions right now if you
have a pre-existing condition you have a
severe form of cancer or something else
and you don't have insurance and your
employer does not cover it or maybe
you're unemployed and you try to get
insurance on your own you're likely to
either be denied or if you are offered
insurance it will be ridiculously
expensive and that's because the
insurance company knows that they're
going to take a huge loss on paying all
of your medical expenses the the
affordable care act says you can no
longer base the premiums or whether or
not you're going to give someone
coverage based on pre-existing
conditions people will be give charged
premiums which is essentially how much
you pay for a policy based on age
age and geography so if you have two 40
year olds one one of whom has has the
misfortune of having cancer and the
other who does not have any pre-existing
condition
and they both live in let's say
in
in in virginia under this they would pay
the exact amount of insurance so they
would pay the exact insurance premium
these other two points once again just
make it easier to get insurance
right now if you've ever tried to get
insurance you'll see that it's hard to
compare and contrast policies really
understand what you're getting and what
you're not getting and so this part of
the act says that every state will set
up these insurance exchanges which allow
a little bit more transparency on in
terms of buying and selling policies and
then this final part right over here and
this is just an overview i'm not
covering everything not all of the
details is the idea that well the
government will also subsidize people
getting policies especially if they are
in lower income if they're in kind of a
more difficult financial situation
now on top of this if you're deciding
whether or not you support things if you
say well this might be a good idea or
maybe you think it's a bad idea because
you don't like the government forcing
things like this there's also the issue
of there's also the issue of the cost
and this whole thing even though there
might be savings in terms of
lower medical care because people will
get preventative health care and things
like that there is still a net cost to
this and this is going to be primarily
paid for by increasing increasing the
amount the essential medicare tax for
high net for for people with larger
incomes so it's really going to be
larger
larger medicare revenues
medicare
revenues or medicare taxes on people
with larger incomes
larger incomes and this is estimated to
generate about 200 billion a year 210
whatever there are different estimates
here but that's going to be a bear most
of the cost and on top of that there are
some extra fees on insurers and there's
a what's called an excise task which is
a tax it tends to be a large tax tax on
a specific product on what they call
cadillac policies these policies that
are very very very generous
to kind of make up some of the cost of
all of this so once again not going to
take any political sides on this but
hopefully that gives some clarity about
what people are actually debating